Jenna: On this episode of
Travel Dares: Season US,
I'll be playing a different tune
as I learn an iconic craft
in America's Music City.
Last episode, I got a clue
for where I'd end up on this episode.
"Time to build the Music in the City."
So now, I'm here at
Moxy Nashville Downtown,
the only hotel on Honky Tonk Row.
Nashville is also known
as the songwriting capital of the world.
And today, I get to try my hand
at the local craft of guitar making.
I am so excited for this
guitar build workshop.
As someone who loves music,
I can't wait to make a guitar.
Hey, I'm Jenna.
Josh: Hi Jenna, I'm Josh.
Jenna: Hey, Josh.
Josh: Welcome to the workshop.
Jenna: Thanks for having me.
How long have you been doing this?
Josh: This is our ninth year here.
Jenna: And what motivated
you to open this place?
Josh: Well, I moved to
Nashville and I make guitars,
and I know how exciting
it is to make guitars,
so I decided to teach
people how to build guitars.
Jenna: How do the different
elements of the guitar
affect the final product?
The tone, in terms of the shape,
the material, all of that?
Josh: There's a whole bunch of
things that affect the sound,
the electronics affect the sound,
the wood affects the sound,
There's a whole bunch of things.
It's just like cooking.
If you add a little extra something
to your chocolate chip cookies,
Jenna: Right
Josh: They're gonna taste different,
but they're still gonna be awesome.
Jenna: So what do you think
makes this course so unique?
Josh: We do everything in one day.
Nobody in the world can
build a guitar in one day,
but somehow we've been
able to condense everything
into six to eight hours.
Jenna: I think I'm ready to
get started. I'm so excited.
Josh: Let's make some sawdust.
Jenna: Yes!
Josh: I got an apron for you.
Jenna: Is that my name?
Josh: That is your name.
Jenna: I love this so much.
Josh, I feel like this is the beginning
of a beautiful friendship.
Josh: All right, Jenna.
Ready to get started?
Jenna: Yes!
Josh: All right.
The first step that we're gonna do,
is we're gonna sand the guitar bodies.
Jenna: Okay.
Josh: Now, we have to sand the
guitar body nice and smooth
so the wood is smooth
and will absorb the stain a lot better.
So, we are going to sand
the front face first.
We're gonna use the sander
for about two minutes on this.
We're gonna flip it over,
and do the exact same
thing on the backside.
(upbeat bluegrass music)
The next thing that we're going to do is,
we're gonna sand the edges.
And you just go with
the grain a little bit,
until it's nice and smooth.
Now that we're done here,
do you wanna go over to the laser engraver
and add some flair?
Jenna: I love flair.
Josh: Excellent, let's go then.
Jenna: Okay.
(upbeat bluegrass music)
Josh: There it is.
Jenna: That's awesome.
Josh: All right, Jenna.
Jenna: Yes?
Josh: The next step is
staining the guitar body.
This is the finish that you've chosen.
This is a three-tone, faded sunburst.
The recipe is on the back.
We're gonna use three colors,
yellow, red, and a mahogany.
Now, by the time you're done,
I guarantee it's gonna look good.
(upbeat bluegrass music)
Jenna: What do you think?
Josh: I think you did an amazing job.
Jenna: Thank you.
Josh: Congratulations.
Jenna: I'm feeling really good about it.
Josh: So are you ready to
go on to the next step?
Jenna: Mhmm.
Josh: Excellent.
The first thing that we have to do
is we have to put the
tuners onto the guitar.
Jenna: Okay.
Josh: And after we've done that,
then we start assembling
all the other hardware
onto the guitar body.
Jenna: OK.
Josh: Once that's all
done, we put the neck on,
and then, soon after, we're
going to put strings on it
and play it.
Let's get to it.
(upbeat music)
You did it!
Jenna: The guitar's done.
Josh: It's done.
So now, we have to play it.
Are you ready?
Jenna: Yes.
Josh: Okay. Well come this way.
I got a special guest for
you in the other room.
Jenna: Oh, I can't wait to meet them.
Josh: Excellent.
(Max playing guitar)
Max: Oh, hey.
Jenna: Ooo, hi.
Josh: Jenna, this is Nashville
legend, Max T. Barnes.
Max: Hey, how are ya?
Jenna: Hi!
Max: Nice to meet you.
Jenna: It's so nice to meet you, yeah.
Max: What'd y'all do today? Anything?
Jenna: Built a guitar, can you believe it?
Max: You built that?
Jenna: Yes. The whole
thing, start to finish.
Max: Is that right?
Jenna: Yeah, it was incredible.
Max: The color and everything?
Jenna: Stained it at all.
This one is an amazing teacher.
Max: That's amazing.
Josh: Thank you.
Max: Good job.
Jenna: Yeah.
Max: It's a gorgeous guitar.
Well, welcome to Nashville.
Jenna: Thanks for having me.
Max: They call it Music
City, do you know why?
Jenna: I have no idea.
Max: Well, the lore goes,
that there was an insurance company,
in the mid last century,
they had a little radio show
and they would have local people come in
and sing bluegrass and country music,
and they would broadcast that.
And one thing led to another
and it got too big for that,
so they moved into this
neat, old church downtown,
built in the 1800s,
called the Ryman Auditorium,
and they still do concerts there now.
And then they built the
Grand Ole Opry House.
So that's how that all got started,
because the announcer
would call this Music City
and it stuck.
Well, let's see how that thing works.
Shall we plug it in and play together?
Jenna: Yes, I'm very
excited to see how it works.
Max: There you go.
Very good.
All right, well,
have you played a lot of
electric guitar before?
Jenna: I've never played
an electric guitar before.
Max: Have you not? Well, let
me show you a few things.
A few tricks and tips, kid.
(Jenna laughs)
Here's how it goes.
Well, the first thing you gotta know is,
none of this matters,
it's pretty much just all,
you gotta get that face on.
Jenna: I knew it!
Max: You gotta learn
that face right there.
(guitars strumming)
Yeah, that's pretty good.
Jenna: Like that?
Max: That's pretty good.
When you start playing a little bit,
and get your shoulder into it.
(Jenna and Max strumming the guitar)
Max: Big, big ending, ready?
Jenna: Yeah
Max: You go, (Max
strumming guitar quickly)
Then you can take your
pick and go, "Woohoo!"
Jenna: Woohoo!
Max: That's it, welcome to
Nashville, you graduated.
Jenna: Yes! Thanks for having me.
Max: Very good.
(upbeat music)
My day at the Guitar Build Workshop
was such an incredible experience.
I think my favorite part was
watching the assembly of it
and seeing it all come together,
it was just so satisfying.
And I got to build my own custom guitar.
I felt like a total rock star.
When you come to Nashville,
do yourself a favor,
venture off Broadway and
give it a try yourself.
Bartender: Here's your drink and clue.
Jenna: I'll just close out, thanks.
Oh, final clue.
Let's see where we're
going on our last stop.
"Check out these hoppy hot springs."
I dunno, are we gonna be jumping a lot?
I'm not sure, but I'm
very excited to find out.
Until next time.
(upbeat rock music)